в Ізраїлі вже третій день продовжуються
бойові дії армія країни повідомила про
повне відновлення свого контролю в
населених пунктах які зазнали нападу з
боку бойовиків палестинського
радикального руху хамас у суботу 7
жовтня ізраїльтяни прокинулися від
звуків сирен та ракетних обстрілів із
сектору Газа бойовики хамасу проникли на
територію країни у день релігійного
свята сигнали тривоги звучали у багатьох
містах зокрема у тель-авіві та Єрусалимі
соцмережами ширилися відео з загиблими і
жорстоким поводженням із
заручниками Я б сказав що це дуже
страшно насправді Це була найстрашніша
ніч у моєму житті Я був з деякими
туристами з Європи ми були в будівлі
ховаючись під сходами коли влучила
ракета Тому це дуже
важко відповідь Ізраїлю була миттєвою
армія розпочала контртерористичну
операцію залізні мечі в палестинському
секторі
Газа стані війни не на операції не на
обході а На
війні ізраїльські військові мобілізували
тисячі
резервістів ми робимо те що потрібно ми
переможемо потроху все буде
добре У нас є підрозділи які знають як
діяти в подібних ситуаціях вони ходять
від дверей до дверей від дому до дому
стежать за тим щоб на ізраїльській землі
не залишилосяжо терориста і борються з
людьми які підняли зброю проти
нас загалом за оцінками ізраїльської
армії з початку бойових дій убито вже
сотні бойовиків зокрема близько 500 у
секторі Газа прем'єр-міністр Ізраїлю
біньямін нетаньяху попередив що країна
входить у довгу та важку війну а уряд
збирається припинити постачання
електроенергії палива та товарів у
Сектор
Газа все що використовує хамас ми
перетворимо роїни Я кажу мирним жителям
гази йдіть звідти негайно ми
працюватимемо скрізь із усією нашою
міцю ізраїльські сили у ніч на понеділок
9 жовтня завдали ударів по понад 500
цілях у секторі Газа повідомили
військові країни імовірно вже в
найближчі дві доби Ізраїль розпочне
наземну операцію в секторі Газа за
даними ООН більше 123 000 з понад двох
мільйоного населення гази змушені
покинути свої домівки спочатку
масованого нападу на Ізраїль бойовиків
хамасу цивільному населенню складно
залишити Сектор Газа бо це є досить
густонаселена територія ми говоримо про
2 200 ся людей Газа не поділена на
райони тут хамас а тут ні складно
відокремити публічні місця наприклад цей
Відділ поліції або база
хамасу навіть деякі офіси в цивільних
будівлях можуть бути офісами організації
які афілійовані з
хамасом станом на ранок 9 жовтня відомо
про понад 700 загиблих в Ізраїлі та
близько 2 400 потерпілих у газі кажуть
про 436 загиблих і близько
2300 поранених
палестинців палестинські бойовики
заявили що утримують у заручниках понад
130 людей глава ісламського джихаду зіяд
альнахала повідомив що заручники
повернуться додому лише після звільнення
палестинських ув'язнених з ізраїльських
в'язниць окрім запеклих сутичок на
півдні країни Ізраїлю також довелося
тримати оборону на півночі Це почалося
після того як з ліванської території у
бік Ізраїлю було випущено кілька ракет
та мінометних снарядів
хезбула та палестинські угрупування
потужні воні формування які підтримує
Іран давно говорять про об'єднання в
рамках так званої осі опору проте за
словами джерел близьких до угруповання
хезбулла хотіла надіслати палестинцям
сигнал солідарності а ізраїльтянам
чіткий але обмежений сигнал
готовності європейські лідери та США
рішуче засудили атаку хамасу та
висловили повну Солідарність з Ізраїлем
його право захищатися
ці дії є варварськими вони обурливі і їх
нічим абсолютно нічим не можна
виправдати Ізраїль має право захищатися
від цих варварських атак захищати своїх
громадян і переслідувати
нападників глава Європейської комісії
урсула фондерляйн заявила що напад є
тероризмом у його найогиднішій формі
засудив напад на Ізраїль і президент США
назвавши дії хамасу безпрецедентним
терористичним
нападом чи не відверне війна в Ізраїлі
увагу західних партнерів від війни в
Україні та як спалах насильства на
Близькому Сході вплине на подальшу
підтримку України у війні проти Росії
наразі невідомо тим часом в Україні
рішуче засудили напад бойовиків на
Ізраїль і висловили підтримку президент
України Володимир Зеленський порівняв
напад палестинського радикального руху
хамас на Ізраїль із вторгненням Росії в
Україну зокрема він провів паралелі зі
звірствами військ РФ у Бучі Зеленський
також розкритикував позицію Ірану у
зв'язку з війною в Україні і
Ізраїлі Іран не може казати що немає
нічого спільного з тим що відбувається в
Україні якщо продає шахеди Росії Іран не
може казати що немає нічого спільного з
тим що відбувається в Ізраїлі якщо його
офіційні особи заявляють про підтримку
того що відбувається в
Ізраїлі тим часом іранська делегація в
ООН заперечує причетність тагерана до
планування або здійснення атаки хамасу
на Ізраїль єдина арабська країна регіону
яка доєдналася до засудження бойовиків
хамасу Об'єднані Арабські Емірати
позиція ОАЕ помітно відрізняється від
коментарів більшості інших Арабських
країн регіону які поклали
відповідальність на
Ізраїль